well either way icob is going to put a
little pressure on the men's bolt pen
but he did make eight starts for
syracuse this season five and one but
his era
five point three two cuny at third
albie's at second almonti at first three
infielders on the left side against
riley
three two coming struck him out he went
right back to the slider to get him
icoff needing a big pitch and he makes
one to get riley for the second half
so here's swanson who went over three in
the opener i cough with a
door to get out of this inning one two
coming from ikoff to swanson
[Applause]
ground ball and i cost got it son
retired
tight rolled back by jared ikoff in his
first inning as a met
gets out of a bases loaded jam well
somehow he pulled it off a 31 pitch
first inning and the braves come up
empty
no runs one hit no errors three men left
middle of the first atlanta nothing and
the mets coming up the young
right-hander ian anderson 23 years old
6-3 170 pounds is out of rexford new
york and he goes to work versus jonathan
br
there's the one-two swung on and missed
strike three
good change up vr saw a couple of those
and he becomes the first strikeout
victim of the ball game for ian anderson
the last native new yorker to beat two
new york teams on the road in a single
season
took place in 1953
when jim constanti beat brooklyn
and also beat the new york giants
oh ian trying to accomplish that feat
tonight but more importantly get his
team in the win column even up this
series
dominic smith had the big hit in game
one a bases loaded double off shawn
newcombe
smith has the whole left side to play
with if he goes that way hits it over
ozzy's glove into right field acuna
comes up cleanly alonzo chugging for
third the throw he's gonna get him what
a throwing tag
ronald was shallow yeah i was surprised
alonzo was going to be perfectly honest
with you
great throw he was actually past austin
riley but the tag grazed him on the back
and he's out by three feet that brings
james mccann up to the plate
18 pitch inning smith with the lead
not going and a and swinging miss good
fastball for
strikeout number two here in game two of
our double header
after the mets won the opener four to
two the braves and the mets are
scoreless going to the third inning and
jared eichhoff will face freddie freeman
and jared eichhoff strikes out freddie
freeman with the fastball
there's the second strikeout for ikof
and that's the first out in the third so
ikoff
settling in a bit after a rocky
beginning it'll be
mckinney so far ian anderson has given
up two base hits
no runs no walks two strikeouts three
balls and two strikes on mckinney just a
219 hitter
ian looking for his third strikeout 3-2
pitch
swung on and miss good change up again
pulled the string on mckinney three
strikeouts now for ian anderson
so now two out runner at first and
here's anderson who bumped it into a
force play his first time up
and anderson is caught looking side
retired
third strikeout for jared ikhoff he's
got four scoreless innings under his
belt halfway through in game two no
score
well if that's the end for jared
eichhoff tonight it's a job very well
done he has limited the braves to no
runs on three hits
in four shutout innings one hit one left
here in the top of the fourth we'll go
to the home half
good start for anderson in the fourth
one away for alonzo who
picked up an infield hit frames will
have the top of the order in the fifth
inning
looks like we'll see castro for ikof
four shutout frames
and scattered three hits
three strikeouts and three walks
and there's the breaking ball mets
haven't seen much of that it was a
perfect time to break it out a bow
locker
alonzo will take a seat strikeout number
four
for ian anderson that was a beauty ron
lacuna
junior got the first inning started with
a double
made it as far as third but they
couldn't get him home
two balls one strike and a
shot towards center that ball is deep at
the wall it's a line drive home run
number 20 for ronald lacuna junior and
the braves
behind acuna's bat have taken the lead
and the crowd giving him the business
and he says
bring it on 116 mile an hour missile off
his back and the braves take the lead
mckinney
struck out his first time up did not
play in game one other than
to come in defensively and the pitch
swung on a missed
got him that's that way to do it
strikeout number five for ian anderson
80 pitches we go to the sixth he leads
one to nothing
so one out and nobody on jonathan vr
the arc drills one toward the right
field corner and that ball will go back
to the wall
the r heads for second acuna's throw
arrives too late
and jonathan vr has struck with a one
out double in the mids of the tying
running scoring position with one out
take a look at him as he makes the turn
this is a little bit of a
running gingerly there jose peraz has
come into pinch run for him carrying the
tying run
lefty on the mound so lindor will be
swinging it from the right side
ground ball to short peraza runs into
the out of third base
ball hit right in front of him and the
mets tonight have run into two outs at
third base in a one-run
game thank you we've seen some
bad base running in baseball so now it's
pilar
[Applause]
hot shot caught race to the bag and
got him it is a double play
[Applause]
the braves have a one-nothing win for
the moment
now pete beat him beat it just just
barely i think he beat him they do stay
safe and so the game is still
gone so they're loaded with two down
this will be drury up to the plate for
the mets
the o2 popped him up
ozzy drifts out he says he's got it he
does
had him all the way the braves split the
double header
they win it one nothing ian anderson
is the victor and the braves end play
today where they began fellas
five back with two to play in this
series in new york
what a finish to the day well i'll tell
you what the braves have lost a lot of
heartbreaking games in heartbreaking
fashion tonight
kind of the night they got the breaks in
this game some bad base running errors
a line drive that finally went to a guy
caught it
and then gets to third out there look
second
day in a row and a double header one and
one nothing but you'll take them anyway
you can get them
yeah look it's good end of the night i
think realistically you're you're trying
to split
in a double header it's always tough to
sweep especially tough with a guy like
degrom going in one of the games so
good good bounce back in game two good
win for the braves in a much better
position
being five and a half back and seven